well the usual way that people discuss
it is to talk about perfect squares
first so if you have studying the
Pythagorean theorem there's a formula
that the square of the hypotenuse is the
sum of the two squares of the sides of a
right triangle so you might ask if the
sides of a right triangle are whole
numbers might it happen that the
hypotenuse is also a whole number
they're called Pythagorean triples and
the Greeks figured out all of the
Pythagorean triples okay so what
happened next is I think it must have
been very natural to look at the
equation a cubed plus b cubed equals C
cubed and a to the fourth plus B to the
fourth equals C to the fourth and so on
so this is now in the realm of algebra
and you can plug in values for a and B
and you'll see that these equations
infinite number of equations seem not to
have solutions well so the story is that
Fermo was reading the text of Diophantus
who is the Greek mathematician best
known for this type of problem and in
the margin of his copy of diophantus he
wrote some marginal notes saying that I
can prove that for higher exponents
bigger than two there are no positive
integer solutions and then famously he
said but my solution is too long to
write in this margin and in his copy of
Diophantus which was inherited by fair
ma son Samuel D fair MA there are many
many marginal notes and Samuel published
a revised version an annotated version
of Diophantus 'iz book in which all of
his father's writings are reproduced and
the reason that FEMA's last theorem was
called from Oz last theorem is that all
of the previously examined marginal
notes proved to be correct or at least
they were proved to be correct or
incorrect mostly correct by
mathematicians after the 17th century
and there was only one assertion that
remained it was the last one on his hit
list and you
again I'm not an expert in the history
of mathematics but I think most people
are convinced that when Fermo was
amateur mathematician he realized he did
have no proof of this thing that he
wrote in the marginal note and in fact
later in his life he devoted a lot of
attention to special cases of that type
of equation it's not just the cubes but
it's the cubes in the fourth powers and
the fifth powers and so on and Fermo
himself later in his life took care of
the fourth powers well the cube
certainly must have bothered him because
he after all he knew about squares and
he knew about fourth powers and cubes
right in the middle the theorem is that
there is no solution
there's no hold on the solution that's
right yeah would it have been or would
it have been more exciting or more
attractive to a mathematician to prove
him wrong and to find these three
numbers that you could plug in that
would do it would that be we better be
more triumphant well it would have been
would have been a very exciting it would
have made lots of news and then the the
proof so to speak would have been simply
a single counter example that would have
fit you know very neatly in a newspaper
column you know and there would have
been some story you know mathematician
in Australia finds the first counter
example to fair laws last theorem
certainly was big news either way the
main thing about fair mahse last theorem
is that over the centuries it gave rise
to a tremendous amount of new and
fruitful mathematics that people really
developed new techniques to try to solve
that equation that proved to be you know
infinitely versatile so a bit like going
to the moon let them develop lots of
other technologies along the way this
was this was the going to the moon at
magma that's that's a fine an analogy I
mean when you formulate a problem in
mathematics
no one knows whether this problem will
really be helpful for mathematics as a
general Enterprise and you know for
whatever reason fair mahse equation has
led to a tremendous amount of new
mathematics
so when I was a graduate student of
we're talking you know roughly 40 years
ago or 45 years ago from Oz Last Theorem
was kind of some curiosity everybody
knew about the problem but no one really
had any approach to it and there was no
kind of fundamental reason why the
problem was going to have a positive
solution and when I was a student there
was a tremendous interest in what are
called elliptic curves and it was
realized around 1968 1969 1970 by andrey
vey and Grolsch Mora and Princeton who
built on the work of Yutaka taniyama who
was his buddy in Tokyo in the 1950s
taniyama had passed away and there was
this gradual understanding that elliptic
curves really were related to modular
forms and again that was some completely
apparently inaccessible outstanding
conjecture and always thought to be an
incredibly hard conjecture and then in
the early 1980s a mathematician came
around and I say that literally because
you know he was sitting here in this
office
his name is Gerhard fry at the time he
was at the university of SAR lawns and
czar broken and he can well I didn't
know it either and he came around and he
had the scheme for relating fair Maas
Last Theorem and the modularity
conjecture somehow he realized for the
first time that if he had a solution to
pheremones equation this would give him
an elliptic curve which apparently could
never be modular I was a little
skeptical because I knew that some of
the things that he said that he needed
in his argument were very hard well for
me a really important thing was in 1985
jean-pierre Serra who is one of my
mathematical heroes in Paris sat down
and kind of tried to distill everything
that had been said about Fry's idea and
he came out with a very clear letter and
this letter
basically said if you can prove this
tiny little result which he called
epsilon because a number in calculus
epsilon is a small number he said if you
can prove this tiny little epsilon then
you can really show that the modularity
conjecture which he called Vey at the
time implies pheromones last theorem so
epsilon became for me a Holy Grail
because not only was it something fairly
well encapsulated and very clear and
this was the kind of thing that I
thought about before without success but
nonetheless while thinking about yet
another problem it occurred to me that I
really had some new information that I
could possibly bring to bear on this
epsilon what I first did was say to
myself what's the simplest possible case
where I can think about this what's the
simplest possible prediction I tried to
settle that I said well you know if you
have to start somewhere
can I look I know about the simplest
case so I had this thing in my mind and
I thought about it off and on during the
academic year 1985-86 and during this
year I was teaching calculus I was busy
with things there you know colleagues
come in they wanted to be on committees
and finally my final grades were
submitted in May 1986 and I started
thinking about this problem again first
I was on the East Coast for a while
going to Europe and then I found myself
in Paris and finally I found myself at
an empty desk in the mock Splunk
Institute and Bonn where I could just
sit and think and I thought about this
yet again is that what you do did you
see the desk with your head in your
hands and think think think of me what
if I was a fly on the wall when you were
trying to crack this problem what would
I say what's it look like well it's
probably you know I had to probably had
a pad of paper in front of me and a
pencil or a pen we didn't really have
computers quite yet although they were
starting to come and when you visit some
Institute you don't have all your stuff
with you you don't have lots of books
you don't have all your paraphernalia so
I was really just kind of sitting there
like that and I started writing you know
and I if if you look in my office you'll
find lots of old pads where I sit and
write and you know the page might start
what do we know what are we trying to do
let's summarize the situation so far
let's let's try this and to my
astonishment I was finally able to to
crack that problem the simplest case of
epsilon so inspiration comes at
preordained times like you sit down and
say okay for the next two hours before I
meet my friend Bob for a hotdog I'm
going to have an inspiration and try and
solve the problem and that's when it
happens it doesn't happen to odd times
when you're lying in bed all it can I
mean if you if you think about something
very intensively then you just carry it
around with you and you know lots of my
colleagues say that while they're
swimming they had some insight or you
know lots of people say in the middle of
the night they jumped up and they said
my god you know why don't I try the
minus sign instead of the plus sign and
this this can indeed happen you know no
you're at a desk not a guy I I think in
this particular situation I was at the
desk I knew for the first time that I
could do something that I hadn't done
before that no one had done before this
was a special case of this so-called
epsilon and I kind of wrote it and
rewrote it just to make sure I was
really right and finally using the very
first Macintosh that I had access to I
typed out a letter to Barry Mazur at
Harvard and I sent him this letter
explaining what I'd done and then I
spent weeks and weeks trying to do the
general case I couldn't see what to do
and then fortunately there was an
International Congress of mathematicians
they occur once every four years on the
campus of UC Berkeley so I was right
here I came back in August for this
International Congress and Barry Mazur
was there and I spoke to him and I said
Barry you know I sent you this letter
explaining how I did a special case and
I really wonder you know what I have to
do now to do the general case and he
looked at me completely quizzically and
he said well but you've already done the
general case and basically
he when he read my letter it just seemed
obvious to him that there was this extra
little thing you carry along as a
supplemental object and this extra thing
would just do the bookkeeping and so we
sat down at this cafe strata which is at
the corner of the Berkeley campus and we
had a cappuccino and he kind of said
well you just carry this around with you
and I was astonished you know it was
like this amazing moment where all of a
sudden I realized that in principle at
least there was no obstacle to proving
this this epsilon conjecture I mean it's
like you know my god you know it's some
special thing you know an angel comes
down and a light shines from the heavens
or something so this was really quite a
thing and since all of my colleagues
were walking around the campus in this
big International Congress I kind of
told you know a number of them that I
had done this thing you know of course
in beginning I was cautious I said well
you know I think I've done this thing
and but people kept running up to me and
I said well is it really true you've
done Epsilon I lived in a world and
think I still do where my colleagues are
very generous with attributions and
praise and there isn't too much of this
kind of race to be the first to publish
and people basically I had little fear
that someone would try to scoop me on
the other hand what was a little
worrisome was that I hadn't written down
all the details you know so I kind of
written down very closely the special
case but I hadn't kind of worried about
writing thing more generally so what
happened was that during the year
following that 1986-87 there was a
special program on algebraic geometry
and arithmetic geometry at the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
in Berkeley the msri so I was up there
with my colleagues and I gave lectures
every week I gave another lecture I was
kind of giving like a mini course on my
proof and when I wasn't lecturing I was
furiously typing into the computer
to try to expand and revise my
manuscript and kind of more and more
details got put in and there were
certainly people in the audience who
were appropriately skeptical they asked
me hard questions and I didn't always
know the answer to the hard questions
you know well how do we really know that
this thing is in such-and-such way and I
would say well you know this was proved
in the 1960s by Brittany but it isn't
quite written down and the place you
expect and then I have to go find
inordinate well epsilon was not small it
was clearly a misnomer and let me just
get up and pull off a reprint what
here's my article was published in 1990
which really makes a lot of time between
1986 and 1990 and they went through like
a book well it's it's a it's more than a
pamphlet if you open up this paper on
the very first or second page there's
fair mahse equation and an elliptic
curve but then they disappear if you
look at the actual article it's more
about the technicalities of the subject
it was a big deal in mathematics it got
uhm it got write-ups in the press
including science magazine if I'm not
mistaken you know whenever there is a
serious announcement of a major theorem
that gets a lot of attention and people
stop what they're doing to try to see
what the basis of the proof is who who
calls it rivets theorem you don't
obviously you don't get to make that
name up if that just sort of bulbs does
it whenever I'm mathematician does this
well um yeah that's right so you
certainly there's a general aversion to
naming things after yourself so very
often people will give lectures and
they'll say such-and-such theorem and
then parentheses they write the name of
the person who proves it and if it's a
theorem that they prove themselves
typically they write the first initial
of their last name or something like
that or else they they don't um they
don't add any attribution and the
listeners understand well this is the
theorem that the person is providing in
this lecture you've done
thing which is important you've built a
bridge between two things which neither
of which are on solid ground yet they
well that's right so the what I what I
showed was that this modularity
conjecture which was thought to be was
was felt to be true
but wasn't expected to be provable I
showed that that thing actually implies
pheromones last there I think the main
takeaway from my theorem was that since
the vague conjecture of shamora taniyama
was likely to be true that now you
should think that pheromones last
theorem was likely to be true for
example it probably wouldn't have been a
really good idea to spend a lot of
computing power looking for a
counterexample to fear laws Last Theorem
where was Andrew walls he was in the
room well that was the whole thing so
Andrew Wiles you know of course he came
around a few times I guess but basically
he was holed up in his attic and I
didn't know that and I think most people
didn't know that so he was I mean it's
his it's his statement that he was
certainly intrigued by fair mahse Last
Theorem as a child and that as soon as
he heard about this bridge he decided to
try to prove the modularity theorem
because of its relation to pheromones
Last Theorem so was it sort of the
situation that Andrew Wiles wanted to
prove from ours Last Theorem by any
means possible and you'd given him a new
means that's what he says I mean if this
is surprising to me because modularity
theorem by itself is a tremendous prize
and you know it seems kind of strange
that you needed the motivation of
fairmont
to go and try to prove it if you thought
that there was some way that's not right
well anyway that's that's that's that's
what he said so yeah we were all
together meaning kind of lots of people
in the subject in a conference in
Cambridge England in June 1993 and
usually go to a conference and you see
the list of speakers and you know each
speaker has an hour and the thing had
been set up so that Andrew Wiles had
three hours so he asked the organizers
he said I have something I want to
discuss and it will take me three hours
and I'd like those slots I said okay and
then in the first lecture you could see
he was proving he was starting to prove
the modularity of some class of elliptic
curves but the class of elliptic curves
at least in the first lecture had no
intersection with a class that you
needed for fair mahse Last Theorem but
then the second lecture got a lot closer
and it became more and more apparent to
people at the conference that in the
third lecture he was going to be able to
do enough to get fair mods Last Theorem
the crowd was growing so a lot of the
mathematicians you know brought their
colleagues who happen to be in Cambridge
and you know some of their family
members and I think there was a little
doubt that he would announce a proof of
pheromones Last Theorem so I came and I
sat in the front row Center and brought
my camera and snapped a picture of it I
was another moment when you know it's
kind of time stopped and when I first
realized what was going to happen and
then you know when it actually did
happen there was some frenzy of activity
I mean the director of the Isaac Newton
Institute where these lectures were held
had ordered a case of Napa Valley brute
of champagne for the end of the lecture
and his after the lecture we came out
into the you know common area and they
these all these champagne flutes were
produced and these bottles started
popping and you know it was it was kind
of really an amazing thing between the
time when you rebuilt your bridge and
you published your paper and this
lecture today drew I would call you
aright you and asked for help not a word
not a word you had no idea I no idea
what he was doing um he was though he
wasn't like a nobody oh absolutely
he was he was a friend and a colleague I
first met him when he was a graduate
student in Cambridge and in fact when I
first came to Berkeley the first year
that I was here he was one of the first
people that I invited he came and spent
a week and gave a lecture or two do you
like that do you like that he kept it a
secret does that make it like a nice
surprise party or to this day you feel
baffled by I mean you seem a lot more
collegiate you're telling me when you
solve your thing you were running
telling everyone and he's he's quite
secretive well it's very unusual
behavior and you know you can say in
retrospect that it was really justified
because he was afraid that people would
kind of jump all over it because of the
importance of the modularity conjecture
and fair laws Last Theorem
but he he did not tell me what he was
doing he did confide and two of his
colleagues at Princeton as he was giving
his graduate course where he was working
out the ideas that were instrumental in
his paper I think it was only a few days
later that I got a copy of this
manuscript and the manuscript was very
thick you know it was like 300 pages
single-spaced you know typeset by text
mathematics typesetting program and we
were supposed to be the kind of referees
looking at different parts of the paper
and I was assigned to a part that turned
out to be problem free and the cats
looked at apart that turn out to have
problems a problem was that shattering
for you as a G like that does it make
you think this is good you know I like
the rigor I like this is how mathematics
works or was it really deflating after
the high of the champagne I mean finding
the problem well um one of the aspects
of the whole thing is that I had gone
out pretty far on a limb telling
everybody that Andrew Wiles had proved
this thing and the way that started was
that when the New York Times first heard
about his announcement they asked to
speak to him and Andrew turned to me and
said Ken you know you speak to Gino
colada so I went and went upstairs and
spoke to her for a very long time
explaining the whole thing and then
somehow the media kept calling me
because it was understood that somehow I
was as designated spokesperson so I
spent that entire summer lecturing about
his theorem
and fielding phone calls from the press
hello hello after the wilds announcement
did cats find oh I think it was like two
weeks what happens in mathematics is if
you have a proof that seems to really be
seems to have a lot of internal logic to
it and there's something that's wrong
with the proof your immediate reaction
is to say well you know this is just
some technical problem that I need to
fix and I think that Andrew Wiles when
he found out about the gap expected that
he would be able to repair it in short
order so it really took a while before
there was realization on his part that
this was a serious problem that couldn't
be fixed immediately just by the tools
in front of him if you were the person
who was taking all the calls from the
press for whatever reason did that mean
you will you were contacting Andrew
Wiles a lot and saying can you give me
an update because I'm getting all these
calls made I don't know what to tell
them like were you calling him for
updates so you knew what to say or was
he any contrary not especially he kind
of went dark he was working on on
mathematics and I wasn't wasn't getting
a lot of information out of him at that
time you know it was all poisoning the
balance right I mean wasn't clear
whether or not this would get repaired
or not and then you know wonderfully it
turned out that there was this repair to
the proof really some completely new
insight actually by Andrew Wiles and
Richard Taylor who worked together over
the summer and this would be the summer
1994 and they had a preprint out in in
the fall of 1994 where they explained
their new method which is now called the
Taylor wilds method and that really
circumvented a lot of the more
complicated arguments in the original
preprint and the two articles were
published together the following summer
which is the summer of 1995
in the annals of mathematics it was a
relief but it was it was not a kind of
joyous relief you know and Richard
Taylor came to me one day again at msri
where I happen to be in fall of 1994 and
he said we have some good news for you
and then the next day he handed me a
copy of this paper so that was kind of
very good and you know I don't remember
there being a huge celebration on the
moment of the release of that reprint
but it just kind of gradually built
people understood that the proof was
complete and then there was a very large
instructional conference at Boston
University in the summer of 1995
different people got up and explained
the different elements of the proof well
it was a fabulous piece of mathematics
as impressed by what what I did and the
press as I am about my own work I mean
I'm even much more impressed by what
they did they had some really new
insight and this insight has percolated
through our whole subject for the last
20 years one way to say what they did is
they showed that somehow modularity is
contagious in the sense that if you have
something that has a little piece of it
being modular you can parlay that into
modularity of a full object
first of all Wiles was obviously
intensely driven to do this he was
really motivated and he said you know
I'm going to do this one way or another
and he brought in all sorts of different
techniques that hadn't been related to
the problem before what's what's amazing
for example there's a whole subject in
algebraic geometry called deformation
theory that was going on when I was a
graduate student that I didn't learn I
thought that was really far removed from
anything involving elliptic curves and
in the years before Wiles his
announcement Barry Mazur had developed
this new tech
week of deformation theory and Galois
representations and it turned out to be
exactly what Wiles needed the language
and the techniques that he needed for
his discussion and so you know something
that seems to be far away
technically turn out to be crucial well
I think you know just informally
everyone referred to it as the proof of
Fermat's Last Theorem but in fact when
you when you looked at the article just
like my article it was something
internal to the theory of modular forms
and Galois representations and while
this article in my article share the
trait that pheromones equation occurs
exactly once in the article in the
beginning and then you get down to the
real stuff I'm very happy with the
recognition that I've gotten and I'm
very proud of what I did and I when
students come into my classes they know
about my role in pheromones Last Theorem
a lot of them have seen the video that
was broadcast on nova and BBC and i
think you know if you do something very
very very very famous then you have an
uncor problem where people say you know
what great thing you're going to do next
and i try to be more or less a normal
guy and not you know walk around with
angels on my shoulder
Esprit to rediscover what firm as proof
might have been is that they have widely
helped that he had done it or had he
disclaimed like was he telling the truth
I think by the time we get to the 20th
century it's quite clear that this is an
incredibly complex problem